ciao ragazzi e arrivato il momento
questa è l'ultima puntata di cucina
buttata di questa stagione ripartiremo a
settembre ma per il momento godiamoci le
lacrime che fanno share
per questo evento così speciale
ovviamente due idee la prima era quella
di utilizzare un consiglio che mi è
stato dato da un ragazzo che non ricordo
dove ho incontrato manco con quel che mi
ha detto guarda dovresti provare a
prendere il google assistant e farti
dire a voce
una ricetta e tu la devi seguire ma allo
stesso tempo voglio fare i macaron che
sono carini colorati teneri poi sapete
cosa succede che dopo giugno
finisce il pride quindi tutti i gay
vanno a riposarsi nelle loro caverne per
uscire poi il primo il genio dell'altro
no dopo e quindi anche un modo capito
per far capire che l'omosessualità è
sempre di trovare dietro di voi per me
ho pensato di unire due video e di
chiedere al google assistan come fare i
macaron di ogni un nome è il google ciao
mi dispiace per dati queste informazioni
devi prima autorità li modifica le
impostazioni dell'assistente google sul
telefono ma questa non è nemmeno una
partnership propagata quindi c'è magari
google ecco se vogliamo mettere in
contatto con giallo zafferano
certo prova ad ascoltare questa stazione
il conforto su youtube music
stazione con forza partito il lungo
viaggio
vabbè chiedi a giallo zafferano come si
fanno i macarons ti propongo macarons
matheron multicolor una carona caramello
salato quale vuoi preparare macarons
multicolor macarons multicolor è una
ricetta per 60 pezzi di difficoltà
elevata serviranno 50 minuti per la
preparazione tra i dieci minuti per la
cottura
la signorina dell'allevatore elenca gli
ingredienti ingredienti per 60 macarons
farina di mandorle 200 grammi zucchero
200 g di zucchero bene per sempre 50
grammi album i 150 gradi sul latte
condensato 50 grammi acqua 50mila
viola rosa giallo ha ragione posso dirti
il prossimo gruppo di ingredienti dati
più informazioni sulla ricetta o
possiamo prepararla insieme cosa
preferisci fare allora famiglia altro
ingrediente per la farcitura panna
fresca liquida 300 millilitri il
cioccolato bianco 80 gran latte
condensato 60 grammi gelatina in fogli 8
grammi
posso darti più informazioni sulla
ricetta o possiamo prepararla insieme
cosa preferisci fare prendere una
boccata d'aria
non voglio fare il petto di pollo
all'arancia macarons multicolore e
potrebbe piacere il petto di quando non
altro il collo con salsa di soia con de
luca
macarons multicolor mancherà un ultimo
ottanta pezzi ora possiamo tornare a
cucinare o cercare una dalla ricetta
cosa vuoi fare torni arti ripetere
torniamo a cucinare torniamo a cucinare
cosa preferisci fare prezzi silenzio
ecco stiamo per fare pollo all'arancia
con l'america base dei macarons
setacciate in una ciotola la farina di
mandorle con lo zucchero a velo poi mite
metà degli albumi e mescolate con un
cucchiaio per amalgamare il composto
incorporate sempre mescolando il latte
condensato e tenete da parte il composto
per 60 una fava sicilia
[Musica]
quando sei pronto per il prossimo step
di gli ok google avanti silenzio farò
calcolate che sono molto difficili ma
caro natale non ho capito
vuoi che ti ripeto all'ultimo passaggio
tanti no grazie va bene così sto da dio
a parte in un padellino detto ok google
nicolò fermati si è arrabbiata questi
non si sa son mica c'è da quando ti fai
le problematiche per setaccio 67 grammi
ciao secca la casacca la casacca la
casacca lei sbaglia a pronunciare alcuni
ingredienti cose zucchero a velo
oggi ti suggerisco io lo so costante il
latte condensato che erano 50 grammi non
è molto invitante creatura lì per dire
che ne so con la l'arancia ricco guarda
come me la faccio procedi a parte in un
padellino dal fondo stesso aggiungete lo
zucchero semolato e l'acqua mescolate e
iniziate a scaldare a fuoco dolce
controllate con un termometro la
temperatura dello sciroppo che dovrà
arrivare a 121 grandi chances per
renault memoria comunque per fast e
ricette che assurda il grembiule lancia
qua we wish sono false adesso mettiamo i
200 g di zucchero e i 50 ml d'acqua
spostiamoci qua chiaramente ci se non
avete un termometro controllati qua
sotto abbiamo vari link dai più
economici ai più che ti potete trapano
il portafogli
monta nel merito la restante metà degli
album il 65 grammi in un'atra
l'italianità di frusta o con la frusta
elettrica e quando saranno da esseri
abbassare la velocità della frusta e
versate articolo sciroppo di zucchero
continuando a contare fino a quando la
meringa si sarà raffreddata
completamente a mano nel calcio denso e
lucido o se sei pronto per i prossimi
step vivi ok google avanti lo fa con sa
come deve metterle una ciotola ti prego
che brutto
vai
quando lo fanno
su che cosa in cui pronto per il bardini
facciamo per questo non ci mettiamo
sarebbe come se faccio faccia effetto se
si sa tutto siamo dell'idea
noi siamo qui schiave di questo essere
aggiungete alla farina di mandorle allo
zucchero a velo gli albumi montati se ti
perché colori facciamo la monna io lo
userei rose l'inter e la tripla carino
ieri diretta royal blue verde blu sono
molto simili come colori vedo poca
luminosità ma scusa ma è ovvio sono
concentrati non c'è la mondello
facciamo così i colori ora ci giochiamo
tu sei democratico o sentiranno allora
paris lancia un dato a 8 faccio nessun
problema
hai fatto qual è se glielo proprio
questi colori credo ottima idea
gianmarco quella di giocarsela ma perché
si lancia un dato a 20 facce anti nato 3
lancia un dato a 50 facce certamente è
uscito 46 la cia un dado da mille pazzo
che è uscito sei lancia un dado da un
milione settecento 20.400 facce
mi dispiace non so come st de lisa era
molto grande e distribuite l'impasto in
quattro ciotole separate aggiungete i
diversi coloranti liquidi o in polvere
poco alla volta fino ad ottenere latita
de rivelata invece vista la differenza
un'altra cosa con le prescelte gianmarco
il critico
wow no è arancione come gianmarco non
ammesso di nascosto
non so che non avrei saputo se
picchiarti un premio ok ragazzi ci
abbiamo sono io mi basta e trasferitelo
in una sacca poche con bocchetta liscia
di 8 nodi di mm di diametro formate
delle piccole
direttamente su una teglia rivestita con
carta da forno lascerete riposare 20 di
batteria le palline se appiattiranno
leggermente da soli diventeranno
perfettamente lisci in su pertite
ragazzi sotto uno dei miei video ne
hanno dato un consiglio per stendere
bene la carta da forno e questo
consiglio adesso non vedo l'ora di
metterlo in pratica per la prima volta
per invece la carta la bagnate la
strizzate anno ma non va bene con quelli
e le ha buttate perché si attacca
perfetta vabbè continua a fare solamente
figuracce io sul web
tornate le righe di maccarone e
lasciatele raffreddare su una gratella
troppo forti eccolo questo è avvenuto
giusto io ti vedo bene di meglio è
infornate una teglia una volta in forno
ventilato preriscaldato a 160 gradi
celsius per circa 10 minuti
si sconsiglia il forno statico trascorso
quel tempo lascia l'insegnamento della
primi minuti sono mostruosi questa si
salva forse vaie preghiamo dio
incrociamo le dita
mettiamo un pochino in ordine fermi per
miracolo dolore buonissimo si sono
gonfiati carinissimi sono mostruosi però
certo tipo terra la bruttezza
intanto occupatevi della trova
ammorbidite la gelatina ponendo la
pertite minuti in una ciotola con acqua
preda google 13 a scaglioni queste cose
ma poteva dire prima di ammorbidire la
gelatina che questa è acqua
questo tipo enrico dove sei tu trascorso
questo tempo strizzatela bene eni del 50
millilitri di panna tiepida
mescolate con un cucchiaio per
amalgamarlo large e tutto il mondo della
mia vita e non so se riuscirò ad
arrivare alla fine di questa cosa
difficilissima panna tiepida grande se
ti evita ragazzi da troppo tempo non
facciamo una cosa al microfono
ma che fine ha fatto il micro no
dobbiamo usare la cucina ma chi è chi la
usa la cucina
be mi sono tolto
capito stai zitto e sostanziato in cui
questa desse tiepida mi rode micron
micron a parte sciogliete il cioccolato
bianco a bagnomaria o nel microonde poi
unite la miscela di panna e gelatina
mescolando con un cucchiaio però segreto
tra loro c è quantomeno di vanto montate
a neve pendolismo alla panna fresca enit
e per ultimo il latte condensato
mescolando con un cucchiaio fino ad
ottenere un composto omogeneo per kit è
composto di panna montata al cioccolato
mescolando delicatamente per non
scordare la panda così proprio cioè
siamo diventati siamo diventati anche
araba resto qui con molta tranquillità e
poi dobbiamo unire tutto cioè quello si
unisce a quello che si usa questo quindi
cuamm e mentre lui fa quello io unisco
al cioccolato bianco la panna con la
gelatina continua ultima se bravissimo
avanti ha detto piero
non ho capito non ha distribuiti gli
impasti infornati una sedia a 50.000
edifica quando vuoi ragazzi e acqua
un altro punto potrete comporre la
carron
disponete la farcitura al cioccolato
bianco con la sac à poche sulla parte
piatta delle piccole derive ricoprite
l'altra meta molto delicatamente
ripetere lo stesso piatto riportare
prima di servire in a caronno multicolor
e consigliabile conservati in
frigorifero per una notte sulla
preparazione di macarons multicolor a e
terminata
vuoi fare una nuova ricerca o conoscere
le ricette consigli o mai più mai più
allora questo tipo afferma parole qui
alla fine dice fatto un giorno è
vergognoso terribile ho sbagliato tutto
io ragazzi siamo arrivati veramente alla
fine di questo fallimento su tutta la
linea venite a provarli arriverà lui
guarda quello esatto se poi prendendo io
prendo quello chiaro come anche cioè che
domande
cioè noi abbiamo finito così in ultimo
shooting di cucina butta la pasta ma io
non ho mai assaggiato questa pietanza
ma questa fa abbastanza cacare abbiamo
aspettato tre ore tre giorni giorno ci
voleva fare quell altra no noi chiudiamo
questa rubrica nel modo in cui abbiamo
iniziato male
che altro dire questo non è un addio noi
andremo in questa settimana che viene in
tour per tutta l'italia
dovremmo ringraziare a casa almeno
alcuni di voi che hanno preso parte al
willian al progetto william per
ringraziarvi dal vivo magari
organizzeremo qualcosa di speciale
potete seguire tutto quanto su instagram
perché vi terremo aggiornati e poi fare
mondi dalla fine per far vedere un
pochino che cosa abbiamo fatto
se qualcuno di voi un pasticcere e sa
che cosa ho sbagliato cioè e sa che cosa
ho fatto bene se c'è stato saper qua
sotto se lo vorrete fare anche voi tagga
temi su instagram fatemi sapere se siete
riusciti a farcela perché non capisco
minimamente nulla zero manualità ma
soprattutto questa è stata la vera
disgrazia per quanto mi riguarda se vi è
piaciuto questo video e siete dei
masochisti
mettete un pollice in su commentate
iscrivetevi attivate le campane delle
notifiche noi no non ci vediamo che stai
facendo
sono mangio york noi ci vedremo
quest'estate è con degli episodi un
pochino speciali fuori poi dare origine
a questa estate faremo delle cose un
pochino nuove quindi comunque rimanete
attivi sappiate che posso instagram su
youtube usciranno insomma delle cose che
spero vi possono piacere anche se non
rientrano in quella che è stata tra
virgolette alla programmazione fino
adesso io vi mando un bacio grandissimo
e ci vediamo a questo punto mi sa che
non ci vediamo ciao
ma l'estate
certo perché voi ragazzi ciao ciao ciao